pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dépêche toi si tu vois quelqu'un tue
tous
non mais si ça plaide ici
non ça fait une heure je crois qu'il ya
personne tuée voulaient ménager
non j'ai emménagé au travers et qui
pleure le pauvre mais j'ai pas de bébé
fait pas toujours ce qu'on veut dans la
vie
sur mon téléphone je ne pouvais pas
payer d'envoyer j'ai payé payé en plus
certains anniversaires selma
on essaie comme des rats
on sérieusement qu'est ce que tu vas
faire ça
je peux te loger deux ou trois jours pas
plus trouvé nerveuse sa terreur on a
décidé qu'on ne voulait pas vivre
ensemble on va passer des rosés tout
seul
mais qu'est ce que tu fais là tu es chez
toi ou je t'emmène
je vais m'arrêter là
si ou ailleurs quitte à se débrouiller
[Applaudissements]
en route vers le nord pour étaient 200
francs 300 non mais c'est pas ça je veux
un lit juste un lit je peux pas demander
à françois est de partir pour te faire
de la place à rien c'est c'est yves tu
te souviens le garçon qui passait bien
ouais mais il s'en va il peut pas rester
déjà c'est ennuis avec elle comme ça
alors c'est bête
j'adore mes jolis garçons et voilà tu es
si tu t'installes ça va faire d'une
histoire à n'en plus finir les ailes et
commenta françois un leader tours
l'internaute cathcart toi si on te vois
je suis fou du mois tu as de la chance
que je devais amour tu m'en veux pas
qu'on laisse tomber c'est pas grave phil
chassagny face
c'est le destin
marc rené m'a proposé de travailler avec
lui à la brocante marché aux la jument
bien que je fais avec toi non mais
qu'est ce que tu veux tu es trop bien
pendant patelli jointe est trop riche
trop tout moi qu'est-ce que je vais là
dedans mais si tuer l'amant d'une femme
extraordinaire alors jacqueline sur
l'école en manger non ou alors des
naturel y en as tu c'est ici même que
les rouges assure même que tu as mangé
un petit temps en temps à les fils
la venue du renonce à tous tes principes
alors
jarry où ça va pas j'en connais tu sais
lire un soupir bien souvent date
souvenir
tu as besoin de tomber amoureuse si ça
pouvait tout résoudre
jusqu'à présent ça m'a pas tellement
réussi autre chose on apprend à marcher
sur un fil et puis on va s'entraîner
dans un cirque ça doit vous lisez dans
mes pensées ou à les biens chinois 8 eu
lieu au le moins cher possible c'est la
dèche
j'ai tué jour un point seulement
j'ai très beau simple
10dans
c'était pas mal d'emplois
non mais dites sans bousculer bienvenu
blanche
trois gardes les petits lu ici on en
mangerait pas tout puisqu'il est encore
une fois champion rico c'est la
meilleure façon de s'en débarrasser
parce que ferais tu roules une roue
premier xxe tu veux pas me débarrasser
livre quand même fait installer à la
main sur ce point que si on fait ça y
ait a eu depuis le temps non justement
jeudi trois jours pas plus et ça fait
une semaine hippique jamais j'aurais dû
très présent bon alors on dîne puis
ensemble
je tends voudrait pas non mais si on
dîne ensemble c'est parce qu'il est à la
maison que chinois ou italiens
[Musique]
comme ça me fait ça génial
c'est un métier de langue ça
[Musique]
prononcez tu fais ça c'est normal qu'ils
auraient des poumons qui papillonne
[Musique]
kirk hammett reçues féminin si sensible
également exerce une profession leurs
marques pour moi c'est la fibre
maternelle tu vois un peu tu prends la
wehrmacht cette histoire mais qu'est ce
que tu veuilles pas j'en sais rien à me
reposer ça depuis que je vis seule je
suis pas plus heureuse mais je suis
tellement ma marotte c'est parce que tu
tombes il faut choisir correctement je
vais pas pressé je suis bien comme ça
j'allais gagner mais tout de même le
type bio awsat yport parler avec toi qui
as tant que tu reviennes pop qui lui
donne sont eux qui me prend au sud
lorsque j'ai découvert le bleu je peux
plus voir notre couleur qui a vu rhône
et bien sûr c'était par ailleurs
aujourd'hui c'est pas des grands enjeux
de cette toile voilà admis à princess
yachts le port cieux c'est pas ça qui
devrait tout de même de remettre rené va
engager quelqu'un d'autre écoute il
n'était pas là hier et aujourd'hui il y
avait sûrement personne n'a même pas
essayé
c'est tellement insupportable ma part
chez toi c'est pas ça alors qu'on on
avait dit trois jours je vais pas du
tout que tu as posé à ce pont qui
transforme tout ce que je dis je n'ai
pas envie qu'on devienne un vieux couple
et gris c'est tout ce que tu fais je te
laisse tranquille puisque je te dérange
pas ce que tu fous là désolé de ton
combat avec ma toile mais les pacers
j'ai prévenu sonia parce que vu wall a
fait comme si elle s'en foutait
tu t'attendais à autre chose ce poison
samarou tétouan et gonfle
et combien de litres ou d'ailleurs ces
matelas pneumatique souffle c'est bon
pour tous pour vos épées choix parce que
j'ai sommeil
je t'emmerde
en fait pas si mon viendra je serais
assez grande pour te lire
je pense que tu voulais faire de
l'archéologie
tu serais même pas foutu de trouver un
temps plein sur d'accord dit oui là non
je serai intraitable à bien je vais
dormir par terre et c'est toi qui va me
culpabiliser les jours je comprends
sonia si c'est madame l'ingénieur aussi
malin il pas déjà assez peur non non
rassure toi je me suis fait remplacer
pour l'étude aujourd'hui on a une
stagiaire dans sa publiciste arrive à
supporter ça toute la journée de
nombreuses qu'en face des papes au
risation profond j'aurais préféré
toujours le téléphone tu veux dire que
tu n'es pas là ça fait 3 hop soul est si
grave mademoiselle là-bas ou lewis on
pourra bien sûr en tout cas c'est une
bonne humeur ça fait plaisir
tu veux parler de ce petit bain de
soleil que tu veux parler lives
non pas de ses nouvelles non je me suis
pas taper une demi heure de métro pour
voir les pieds en passer le gros spa 500
à la bouche
si vous continuez à bouter comme sa
mademoiselle là bas vous allez tout
casser ça peut aller mademoiselle là bas
oui oui ça va aller ça va aller bien sûr
ça va aller si vous passez pas tous les
cinq minutes pour me demander si ça va
allez sortez moi les plans et moi là
dedans je sais pas demandé de le loger
tu m'as pas laissé le choix à quoi vous
n'allez pas vous faire la gueule comme
ça éternellement equity fait ce qu'il
veut de toi tu fais ce que tu veux et
puis moi j'ai du travail par une attaque
oui chacun fait ce qu'il veut tout le
monde est malheureux et ses minots qui
va encore se débrouiller tout seul c'est
tout ce qu'elle te dit elle m'a aussi
demandé du passé les pinces
je pense que cela ne te passionne pas
comme enseigne elle a besoin d'un homme
qui tienne debout tout seul ouais t'as
raison
j'y peux rien moi simplement de tout le
temps tu sais l'importance n'est pas que
tu viennes à vieux os est dépassé mais
qui prennent un petit peu ta vie en
raison je peux rien moi j'arrive pas je
sais pas comment vous faites mais avec
vous on dirait que tout est toujours
simple énoncé pas simple
le vent se précipitent pas sur les
autres texane europe
il faut que tu apprennes à assumer tout
seul elle n'a qu'a réussi à mettre 3 t à
apporter
moi je me coucherai boujou va renaître
matin tu vas salle de bain je termine de
trois cahiers j'arrive
[Musique]
on peut pas dire que le chagrin par
d'insomniac aurait quand même pu
attendre trois minutes
excusez moi mon ami mais j'ai besoin de
la salle de bain senderos politique oui
mais moi ça me gêne
[Applaudissements]
yacé
pourquoi calme du campo militaire je
voulais juste te récupérer moggi
alors tu dors
l es tu dors mois dort mais j'ai jamais
sommeil
tiens
j'étais à porter ça
la boîte mais j'avais pas sommeil mais
j'avais une de ces sources
je fais un effort bond en est un qui
peut nous au ski encore c'est je t'aime
beaucoup un jour soit en portrait
d'accord
bonsoir
trois jeunes hommes encore sonia
tu crois que non je me demande vraiment
pourquoi je me mets dans vos affaires
écoute séparez vous pleurez chacun dans
votre truc qui coince et tout ce que
vous méritez sait combien 250 c'est bon
il faut pas dire c'est beau il faut dire
c'est cher mais c'est beaucoup trop cher
non mais tu te rends compte se dire
comment on vit chacun dans son petit
coin avec écoute avec ses petites manies
ça va être bien quand on aura 50 ans 230
panorama pas 150 je le veux même à 230
ne te connaissent pas
écoute
c'est pas yves qui est gênant c'est mon
appartement qui est trop petit sinon ça
serait tout à gré de prendre un
appartement 180 non pas un peuple
ecoute-moi samir si on avait eu à trois
ou quatre pièces à nous deux on aurait
très bien pu héberger y va vous vous
seriez jamais engueulé il aurait eu sa
chance selon lui que ça a été
sympathique deux mamans volutes 200
tumeurs non plus il ya ce site
je suis comme ça faut que marine tout
bas et ça s'appelle les achats impulsifs
et marchand tente beaucoup sur les
chagrins d'amour pour leur chiffre
d'affaires pour sonia tu te rends compte
si on met nos deux loyers ensemble on se
retrouve avec un appartement beaucoup
plus grand chacun notre chambre
es tu vivrais avec lui sans vivre avec
nous c'est ça le vieux mythe de la
communauté tout le monde il est beau
tout le monde il est gentil cboe
s'émerveille on te tue mais non on
partage parce que rien en partage le
loyer l'électricité la cuisine tout ce
qui est important
c'est combien de tableaux 30 francs
sécher
sonia c'est vraiment pas cher c'est pas
la peine de discuter
bilan 10
mais
c'est sûr que tu veux
quiconque s'en va comme ça l'autre jour
on me laisse planté là
pleure comme bb portable on pense à mon
idée du vérin en tout cas moi je suis
partant ça dépend de toi tu offres tv
donnera sa 3 ça veut dire que l'accès ne
t'emballe pas mais c'est déjà un geste
tu vas les avoir pour la remercier et
puis tu vas lui dire que tu as eu tort
tu vas la flatter et puis tu l'as des
cibles encore vous bon j'y réfléchis
mais dans une situation post parce que
si je refusais ne pouvait rien faire
semblant bon alors attention
premièrement il faut que l'appartement
soit vraiment un grand deuxièmement j'ai
pas le temps de chercher les plus
troisième âge faut pas s'imaginer qu'on
est marié
chacun sa chambre et encore pas tous les
soirs ensemble on va s'occuper de tout
on va te trouver un petit palais à mon
avis une fille du genre de seniors
accepté une proposition comme celle là
il peut considérer qu'il s'agit en
quelque sorte d'une confirmation d'amour
oui agnès est tout à fait d'accord
d'ailleurs sony a fait le bon choix à la
tellement besoin d'un papa oui et c'est
tellement gentil de la part d' il de se
sacrifier pour elle sonia nous dit
toujours rien mais elle a de plus en
plus de mal à s'empêcher de rire et de
manifester son intense bonheur attention
chers auditeurs encore quelques instants
et elle va rires non pas encore non oui
là elle rire en fait neuf pièces avec
jardin tout confort alors on pourra même
avoir un poulailler et bien entendu
lui-même un petit potager si vous voulez
alors là c'est formidable je le prends
ce sera 20 mille francs pour la reprise
vingt mille francs et 4000 francs
seulement pour le loyer 4000 francs les
appartements voulait chercher en
fonction du prix à la verse
c'est la chef qui a raison ça va pas
être commode c'est madrid et vous êtes
sûr ça a marché
et bien entendu nous consultons senaux
chez tous les jours dès que nous aurons
ce que vous désirez nous appellerons
tenait signé ici
très bien ces 150 francs pour les frais
d'inscription faut pas payer mais une
annonce un pas dans le journal est en
vérité une au regard et puis vous devant
153 pour le dossier vous rappelle jamais
sont des voleurs et bien sûr tu as payé
7 sur 7 bistrot changeront jamais
je me reconnais pas tenir on chalon le
lycée la mer rossignol quitte à envoyer
encore à cause de moi
joe roth et les sur pattes dans ta
propriété qu'est ce que c'était beau
dillon chez toi et puis quand tu m'a
poussé dans la piscine avec ma robe et
que j'avais pleuré
oh là là quand je pense que j'étais
amoureuse de toi tu cherches un
appartement à une piaule mais cette fois
dans paris tu sèmes arrivé plein de
trucs depuis j'ai quitté le lycée alors
je m'étais donc marié lui j'ai divorcé
il était volée lui c'était ringard de
ces compagnies et toi je donne des cours
de dessin amateurs qui déjà la vente
appelé michel-ange
une fois mon portrait pour propos
toujours aussi beau savais ta photo s'il
y aura du mal d hameçonnage comité t3
foutu de ma gueule
je t'invite à des générateurs et chaleur
comme crysis tes parents ont toujours la
propriété
non mon père est mort on a dû vendre et
puis avec des dettes de plus à chalon
mes parents une petite épicerie à mâcon
ça fait des années tu es vraiment au
courant de rien
[Musique]
alors si je comprends bien si le ménage
à trois quoi pas du tout agnès est une
amie tu verras quand il rencontrera
c'est pas du tout leur genre tu parles
instits et ingénieurs dont spatm à
rendre tous les jours on était
terriblement féministe quoi croit pas du
tout pourquoi tu lis ça on dirait
turkish je sais pas si on arrivera à
trouver parce qu'il leur faut quelque
chose de bien tu vois bâton ingénieur
peut pas chercher elle-même
non mais problème c'est que c'est moi
qui les ai convaincus alors je me sens
responsable il y en a tellement besoin
pour son métier depuis hier ça ira non
j'ai pas tellement à bord il ya du tout
tu vas pas mais c'est avec tout ça parce
que tu veux que je fasse ça lui met
cette pierre est
c'est voir comment échapper à ses
parents imaginons pas du tout comme ça
je te voyais avec des lunettes
merci j'ai fait une gaffe est
susceptible un nouveau paquet de pop
convaincu donc pas tu exagère un peu non
enfin mr je suis chez moi quand même
c'est vrai toute la journée je travaille
le soir je cherche une baraque
absolument introuvable et dangereux
défaut je m'enferme dans la salle de
bain toi tu es tu prêt ça et à ben oui
tu déranges c'est parce que je voulais
comprendre on s'attend au pire si je
dérange alors montré puis après tu ne
laisseras 5 unique qu'est ce que c'est
mon baptême musique tels que le fameux
[Musique]
alors tu vas à la ferme de tes parents
avec ton mini cassettes et puis tu
enregistres tous les bruits et hop avant
de t'endormir tu mets la bande en marche
c'est génial non tu crois qu'on peut lui
des poules sur son balcon sûr que non
pourquoi c'est sûrement défendu du
moment que c'est bon c'est facile c'est
interdit je crois que ça peut être
formidable cette communauté regarde un
peu comme ce soir là on est bien as tu
partes surtout si sonia aussi ces
impacts toit d'or mon petit lapin d'or à
venir à la piscine avec nous dimanche tu
la verras tu vois c'est ça qui me
faudrait un bon combat ricky d'or et pia
puisque it mon boulot je pense que
demain on peut tu crois pas que je vais
passer ma vie dans un supermarché à
coller deux étiquettes on a cherché
autre chose facile toi tu as de
l'instruction mais moins nantis dont
sont portés dans la salle de bain
pourrait dormir avec toi aussi tu
travailles pas demain non comme je bosse
le samedi moi je me reposais mardi
[Applaudissements]
si sonia marche pas pour carey
on mettra 2006 en france elle marche en
toi tu les repas méchoui t'en fais pas
quand vous aurez fini de flirter en vous
attendent
voilà pourquoi je passais des heures
cabaret pas
à dos après un saut qui s'affale
admettra garder les buts
on n'aurait fait qu'une bouchée elle va
plus loin il à entrer dans le douaisis
lui savait pas s'il est mort 2
a perdu son frère
cameron a gagné je suis débile cette
année à prendre chapeau blanc à écoute
si on aime bien tous les deux il n'y a
pas de raison que sony a même pas l est
est jalouse qui tu peux être prudent
même si j'ai dit non tu vois pas ce
qu'on veut de 1607 un peu juste vous ne
vous fatiguez pas trop en fait ça et
c'est pourquoi ici j'avais du temps sous
préfet toute façon c'est votre idée
indien peut que cette épreuve sont
encore connus
situe entre une seule fois dans ma
chambre sens est ravi que je te préviens
tout de suite je m'en vais
wyeth a vite et on écoute sérieusement
si on avait chez par mois trois mille
3000 2 serait déjà fait j'ai
l'impression de passer un examen
puis pas pressé je la connais sa portée
tu sais choix de moi
vous
ange ratoma vous cacher
j'en ai fait
tu verras quand on aura l'appartement
tu sais j'ai téléphoné à mes amis qui
vivent comme ça ça se passe très bien
simplement il 104 c'est plus facile si
on peut la différence est rien mais
c'est comme ça que je sens les choses ou
et voient quatre c'est un bon chiffre
agnès et la maison se sentir un peu à
part alors à l'impression de narration
donne c'est elle qui a eu l'idée
bon écoute et on est trois on est trois
on va pas chercher n'importe qui pour
faire un quatrième soyons réalistes ou
bon ben je vais nager un peu
par contre
pourrait peut-être penser aux problèmes
pratiques on va bientôt se retrouver
avec deux cuisinières de réfrigérateurs
de tournus disque bon alors on vend ce
qui est en double et puis on achète un
lave-vaisselle par exemple
faudra en discuter tu te rends compte le
luxe
elle est sympa pirette
2500 vous êtes sûr absolument
c'est une occasion à saisir c'est le
propriétaire nous en fait pas les
formalités d'expulsion sont déjà remplis
très bon ça avec une blanquette de veau
pièces et puis mon ex mari
ça va peut-être parce que encore une
fois elle même vraiment pas un mail tu
connais pas bien c'est tout tiens ça
sent donc c'est pierrette la cuisine
tous leurs d'apéritif un cardinal avec à
glaçons et un cardinal sais pas ce que
ça va donner
il se prend carrément pour vaucluse je
te mets un disque je commence à me faire
votre idée c'est pas désagréable du tout
je ne sais pas si ça va durer
c'est pas mal
alors comme ça tout le monde participe à
tous chacun son qui travaillent mais moi
je n'ai jamais vu comme ça ça lui a
donné des idées toujours dit que je dois
même d'action est ce que quelqu'un a
quelque chose contre lie à bien au
contraire tu verses le paquet à votre
chien qui dans sa jambe est pas trop
qu'on parle sans arrêt de cet
appartement où elle doit pas très bien
comprendre qu'on tenterait bien l époque
mesquine
elle trouve que c'est une très très
bonne idée et elle est très content de
camp nou mais tout de même ça doit être
un peu dur pour elle on garde la chaîne
parce que la tienne est pas très bonne
[Musique]
carte mais un pote camail ça sera
meilleur mercier est donc un évènement
chouette tas cuisinière appuie sur un
bouton et hop tu n'as pas besoin
d'allumer est dommage tu t'en sers pas
souvent j'ai pas le temps
bah ce poids longue faire la cuisine je
te montrerai des trucs garde la
cuisinière alors et puis je viendrai
vous faire des bons petits plats d'antan
au maire sabri tu veux bien donner tout
a dit cette fille
c'est camille je lui dis qu'elle pouvait
passer c'est bien manger quelques usines
hier soir là je vous l'aï connu à chalon
s'impose en trois mois c'est sérieux
cette histoire de communauté rien de
plus sérieux manque plus que
l'appartement
ça fait trois semaines qu'on cherche et
comme on a tous donné notre avis aux
proprios dans huit jours on est clos
tu ne lâcherai pas allez vous en faites
pas je vous prendrai chez moi devant
team hervé ie7 pire est à riscle euro
vivent avec nous c'est pas moi c'est
quand même drôle c'est votre ami et vous
n'y avait même pas pensé des salles au
fond elle est très agréable à vivre
cette fille moi je sais que je m'entends
bien avec elle mais de là qu'est ce
qu'on risque qu'elles acceptent de se
plier aux règles vous disiez vous même
qu'il faudrait un appartement plus grand
et un peu plus cher écoutez vous pensé à
rien alors vous voulez combien de pièces
5 6 ans le possible si on prend pire est
avec nous bon alors qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
en froid que la raison on aurait pu
penser quand même ben oui c'est vrai on
a vraiment inquiet du salut quand vous
aurez fini votre autocritique on n'est
pas drôle c'est vrai lorsqu'on prend
tellement bien ça c'est votre problème
moi de toute façon les communautés je
n'y crois pas mais comme je n'ai pas
envie que vous coucher sous les ponts
j'ai peut-être quelque chose pour vous
un grand living quatre ou cinq chambres
une entrée une cuisine une salle de bain
comment bien 3000 francs promu fond
c'est juste au dessus de chez moi
le gérant est très gentil même bien je
peux vous devant les formidables votre
appartement ou l'appartement il y aurait
pas voulu et alors
sa tombe est pas tout à vivre tout seul
au beau jeu pour vraiment envie de me
suicider tous les jours mais si j'avais
une corde elle j'ai oublié le sucre auch
pas bouge pas j'y vais je vais poser une
question mais faut que tu sois tout à
fait à l'aise pour répondre parce que
tout moment on peut très bien se
débrouiller sans toi ça te plairait de
vivre avec nous mais je pensais qu'à ça
roi depuis le début
[Musique]
je la prendrai rien que pour ça je peux
rester des heures graves il faut jeunes
très bien surtout si vous n'oubliez pas
d'affaires à voler régulièrement
bon alors vous avez quatre chambres à
coucher de sur la rue et 2 par ici
n'aura qu'à dire qu'il est toi vous
allez vous marier
ça fera plus sérieux les wii puis moi je
serai la jeune fille au pair pour les
enfants plus tard c'est simple c'est ça
c'est ça et que vous prenez les gens
normaux
voyez ils sont très spacieuses elles
sont très bonnes le gérant s'affoler
c'est un bail 3 6 9 oh vous permettez
j'adore les blondes combes et bien
volontiers excusez moi noël après mois
tirées j'essaie d'être aimable c'est la
moindre des choses
oui on va nous on va on va nous brancher
bientôt en 220 alors je me pique mon
amoureux
je la prends un gros zélande l'image des
internautes est vrai qu'à prendre ta
couverture conduit nombre à toi il va
falloir te conter un supplément de
chauffage quand vous voyez les très
grandes et très clair tout un temps je
me dis il va prendre pour une folle
moi pas du tout c'est magnifique c'est
ravissant
qu'est-ce que tu fiches avec ça qu'ils y
trouvaient dans ma chambre mais tu vas
pas dire ça quand même pas si j'aime ça
ces carences personnes l'entrée est
assez grande aussi un comme vous voyez
on pourrait presque en faire une pièce
de réception
alors je vais mettre mon bahut là
puisque c'est prête assez à manger mais
non puisque on mangera dans la cuisine
dont ils sont commentés meubles a battu
pense qu'ils sont tout neufs
mes jambes anciens tu vois c'est
important les mains vous êtes la
meilleure année seulement après
compliment mais je suis certain que tout
va se passer à merveille
d'ailleurs mademoiselle brûlés et une
excellente recommandations un locataire
modèle depuis toujours
ça fait plaisir de voir que vous avez
l'esprit ouvert
c'est vrai d'habitude dans les agences
des comics
bon alors cette deuxième visite ne vous
a pas fait changer d'avis parce qu'il
est encore temps à est ce que vous avez
apporté vos fiches de paie parce que le
loyer est relativement important merci
pas parfait mais quoi vous n'êtes pas
une communauté au moins vous avez de
cépie avec des épingles à nourrice dans
les oreilles ok d'horreur n'hésite pas
la nourrice dans les oreilles
mademoiselle et ingénieurs tout de même
à vous êtes ingénieur mais bravo où on
ne croirait pas ce que vous êtes
tellement tellement charmante sait
écouter le mieux serait que vous signez
toutes les trois
[Musique]
aussi merci signe de mon vrai nom et au
nom de jeune fille ne parle pas de tour
divorce il n'aime pas ça puis vous avez
de l'humour toutes les grâces nous
pouvait se vanter de son prix j'ai
confiance alors ça y est c'est un ordre
tout étant alors mademoiselle et vos
amis sont désormais vos voisins très
bien alors je vais je vais vous laisser
les clés et je reste à votre entière
disposition si vous aviez le moindre
problème
mesdemoiselles messieurs
mais si vos missions vous avez vu que
j'ai eus m'ont gardé l'âme avec brio de
veau aux réfugiés voisin
je me demande comment il a pu croire
qu'il était ingénieur
alors comme ça tu vas mais plus
[Musique]
voir
les chargements nîmois la crèche et
sommiers 11 mars était là pour donner
des conseils
il est bien quelqu'un pour superviser et
encore deux filles ou ses pieds et un
mec
bon les filles vous prenez les petits
paquets ouais en somme il faut que je
réfléchisse à comment tu les trouves
comme moi j'y crois je crois que suis je
prends la blonde au frigo et toi
tu vas quand même pas me dire que tu as
froid qu'est ce que tu crois j'ai les
mains fragiles
eh ben dis donc toi comme brocanteurs tu
vas faire un malheur je m'appelle
pierrette
vous habitez l'immeuble
[Musique]
et
oh
m
[Musique]
j'y arrive pas ne pas montrer c'est
comme ça
ça l'a vraiment facile à coincer vous
et puis du coup c'est au tour du doubs
j'ai dit que je prenais pierrette j'aime
pas conversion ne pensais pas trop si je
lui plais la nasse il te dira que c'est
toi qui a commencé bon alors et camille
tu prends le matelas par là et puis
pyrek tu le prends laïta bon bouillon
des bauges la tête explose bonjour à
tous excusez moi ce serait pour faire
tourner et hamoir ils sont d'une
maladresse je ne vous ai jamais dit mais
il ya deux ans quand je vous ai vu faire
votre déménagement tout seul j'ai été
réellement impressionné mais celui-ci
attend s'arrêter pour vous c'est rien
mais pour nous vous comprenez on est
quatre mais on n'arrive pas à prendre le
sommier descendez ça va vous amusez vous
allez voir
[Musique]
bon je m'en fous
non
c'est pas là c'est là bas désolé
et
balaruc-les-bains
dans le tour
[Musique]
directement dans la chambre
sinon j'ai j'ai fait ma paraplégie un
rendez vous urgent c'est urgent au
moment de remercier lu sur ap
bon tant pis
[Musique]
pour ses collections aux mélodies j'ai
failli mais c'est quand même
l'important c'est de faire ça avec ordre
et méthode heureusement tu es là tu me
file un coup de main j'allume ma
cigarette
ensuite je vais peut-être me douche pour
te détendre un peu après si tu veux je
te ferai un massage fait joli votre
communauté s'était trouvé trois esclaves
quoi au lieu de ruminer toi qui me vaut
d'efforts mais tu ne vois pas non je
n'ai pas regardé
franchement non non non non pas la pala
à la haye c'est que à tout petit peu
plus bas
non à tout petit peu plus haut attendues
à times j'ai déjà j'allume ma petite
cigarette en juin pour la tête et puis
ça c'est le déménagement pour la suite
ça va pas non ça c'est toi donc fait pas
comme ça vous êtes vous empoisonner
éteint sa cigarette tue nous en plus
puis là normalement ils sont amenés à
d'avril ce fait j'ai froid
personne même s'il reste mourir de froid
sonia t'as pas cent balles
je vais rendre à trinité confiance et
maintenant je suis donc trois mois testé
tous vous retrouver en train de chercher
quatre studios n'ont forcément ça va
dégénérer votre truc c'est impossible ou
alors il va falloir des règlements
militaires déjà tout seul c'est pas
facile mais alors là vous êtes tout
simplement en train de multiplier les
angles par quatre non je vais dire
vraiment ça me paraît pas réaliste du
tout est ce qu'il y a
on peut te poser une petite question
pour fait pas ça peut pas mal mais
pourquoi tu es toujours fourré là
[Rires]
[Musique]